[Musik]
richtungswahl auf der insel die briten
stimmen heute auch über den braig setup
streit um klima ziele einige eu länder
stellen sich quer sie fürchten zu hohe
kosten für ein klimaneutrales europa
krach beim pipelineprojekt die usa
drohen bei nordstream 2 mit sanktionen
deutschland verbittet sich jegliche
einmischung
die nachrichten nicht da bis heute mit
christian sievers herzlich willkommen
bei uns und guten abend kristin hat
nachher den sport genannt das ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick in knapp 20 minuten
länge es ist ein entscheidender tag für
großbritannien die briten wählen heute
ein neues parlament und über allem liegt
die frage ob dann der brh exit klar
gemacht wird oder die hängepartie weiter
geht der konservative premierminister
boris johnson will mit einer mehrheit im
unterhaus seinen brachse deal noch vor
weihnachten über die bühne bekommen aber
das schafft hängt entscheidend vom
wahlsystem ab schauen wir uns das an das
ist sehr speziell
insgesamt gibt es 650 wahlkreise und das
gilt anders als bei uns das klassische
mehrheitswahlrecht das heißt wer in
einem wahlkreis auch nur eine stimme
mehr bekommt als die anderen kandidaten
zieht ins parlament ein
sämtliche stimmen für die anderen
bewerber sind verloren also nicht
prozent der zellen am ende sondern die
gewonnenen wahlkreise
das macht diesen tag auch so schwer
vorherzusagen aus london yasin herrlein
über 45 millionen briten dürfen heute
ihre stimme abgeben
wie viele tatsächlich die wahllokale
aufsuchen werden hängt wohl davon ab wie
groß der wille ist die widrigkeiten des
wetters zu überwinden nass und eklig ist
es fast überall manchen teilen des
landes hat es sogar geschneit und
einiges an politikmüdigkeit nach dem
brett chaos der letzten jahre musste
auch noch beiseite geschoben werden ich
wollte eigentlich in der eu bleiben aber
wir müssen das jetzt auf die eine oder
andere art zu ende bringen
ich hoffe dass es ein patt gibt denn
eine mehrheit für die konservativen oder
die labour partei wäre schlecht für
dieses land wir haben armseliger
parteiführer
besagte kandidaten fürs premierminister
amt hier dies nicht ab gleich am morgen
mit gutem beispiel voranzugehen
jeremy kubin der vorsitzende der labour
partei der in sachen braig sieht ein
zweites referendum verspricht kam mit
seiner frau boris johnson von den
konservativen der den exit zum 31 januar
wahr machen will brachte den hund mit
den er sich kürzlich angeschafft hat das
liefert noch bessere bilder und liegt im
trend fotos von vierbeinern vor
wahllokalen scheinen zurzeit sehr
angesagt die umfragen prophezeien
einmütig eine mehrheit für johnstons
konservative allerdings ist das
britische wahlsystem immer für
überraschungen gut
nur eines scheint sicher mit dieser wahl
werden die weichen gestellt für die
lösung der berec sind blockade in die
eine oder andere richtung und dem
prasselnden londoner regen jetzt live
für uns diana zimmermann diana guten
abend was ist das für ein gefühl heute
für die briten schicksalswahl oder eher
lästige pflicht es ist genau weide ist
eine schicksalswahl nicht nur wegen des
krassen parteipolitischen unterschied
zwischen den beiden spitzenkandidaten
die für wirklich völlig unterschiedliche
politik stehen sondern eben auch
deswegen weil heute darüber entschieden
wird ob der brh exit 2020 kommt oder
nicht lässt sich nicht nur wegen des
wetters sondern auch weil viele briten
der politik müde sind
nur wenige setzen heute ihr kreuzchen
hinter einen der spitzenkandidaten aus
vollem herzen
dennoch die wahlbeteiligung scheint hoch
das gilt allgemein als gut für die
oppositionspartei der vorsprung des
johnsons ist in den letzten tagen
geschrumpft und doch sagen ihm die
allermeisten institute eine absolute
mehrheit voraus das wäre das mandat für
seinen harten drechselt kurse und das
würde bedeuten dass der exit am 31
januar 2020 kommt das königreich eu
verlässt so noch kann man wählen diana
woran wird sich denn dieser tag am ende
entscheiden
noch mal deine frage bitte
entschuldigung
noch sind die wahllokale ja offen in
großbritannien woran wird sich denn
dieser tag am ende entscheiden wird sich
dann entscheiden wie viele wähler
taktisch wählen also sich tatsächlich
dafür entscheiden für eine andere partei
zu stimmen als sie eigentlich gerne
würden in der hoffnung dass ein anderer
kandidat verhindert wird das gilt vor
allen dingen für die konservativen
kandidaten die bei exit gegner haben
sich genau ausgerechnet für wen man
stimmen muss um konservative kandidaten
und den br- exit zu verhindern und die
frage ist wie viele wähler diesem aufruf
folgen das wird das ergebnis dass hier
mit großer spannung erwartet wird
beeinflussen
diana live in london herzlichen dank um
23 uhr unserer deutscher zeit gibt es
erste hochrechnungen wie die wahl also
ausgeht darüber halten wir sie online
den ganzen abend über auf dem laufenden
natürlich mit einem live blog auf heute
de und ab 5 uhr 11 live
berichterstattung dort von denen heute +
kollegen und auf diese wahl in
großbritannien gucken sie natürlich auch
bei der eu ganz gespannt was heißt das
für den bhc rexit inmitten dieser
unsicherheit müssen die staats und
regierungschefs der eu bei ihrem gipfel
in brüssel die weichen für die zukunft
stellen
zum einen in sachen klimaschutz der
villa kommissionspräsidentin ursula von
der leyen einen neuen sogenannten green
deal und es geht ums geld darum wie viel
jedes mitgliedsland bis 2027 in die
gemeinschaftskasse einzahlt und wieviel
wieder zurück an die länder fließt aus
brüssel in aragon am morgen brennt das
brüsseler ratsgebäude natürlich nur
symbolisch greenpeace ruft den klima
notstand aus und will druck auf die
staats und regierungschefs machen sich
dringe klima regeln zugibt dass
heutzutage immer noch oft billiger ist
zu fliegen als die bahn zu nehmen
es ist pervers dass unsere regierung
immer nach dem gas und ölunternehmen die
lizenzen geben noch mehr gas noch mehr
öl zu bohren wenn der planet schon dabei
ist zu überhitzen
zeitgleich redet die eu
kommissionspräsident in dem polnischen
premier ins
die wissen er solle sich zur
klimaneutralität bis 2050 bekennen
doch polen pocht gemeinsam mit ungarn
tschechien auf geld aus dem eu-haushalt
um von kohle auf nachhaltige
energieformen umzusteigen
dazu wollen die tschechen nun auch den
atomstrom zählen kernenergie ist saubere
energie ohne emissionen
ich weiß nicht warum so viele länder
damit ein problem haben
das ist nicht nachhaltig und ich das was
auf jeden fall meine regierung
unterstützt das heißt wenn in ländern
einzelnen ländern das machen möchten ist
dass er recht aber auf jeden fall nicht
mit eu geldern die bundeskanzlerin
bekennt sich bei ihrer ankunft zur neuen
eu klimapolitik
deutschland unterstützt die
vorstellungen die ursula von der leyen
dargelegt hat und deutschland hat sich
ja bereits auch zur klimaneutralität bis
2050 verpflichtet kein wort zum zweiten
großen streitthema dem nächsten
siebenjährigen eu haushalt mit dem auch
die klimapolitik finanziert werden soll
litauens präsident wird dafür kämpfen
dass osteuropäische bauern mehr geld
bekommen und demonstrierte mit ihnen vor
dem ratsgebäude wenn auch nur für kurze
zeit
eine kurze in ordnung jetzt noch von
anne gellinek da zeichnet sich ja beim
klima anne der nächste riss durch europa
ab wie sollen da eine gemeinsame
position daraus werden
diese gemeinsame position wird hier im
moment im brüsseler gipfel gebäude noch
gerungen und die gräben zwischen ost und
west in der klimapolitik sind ziemlich
tief die westeuropäer wollen hier mit
einem symbolischen einer symbolischen
unterstützung für die neuen
klimaschutzpläne der neuen eu-kommission
herauskommen die osteuropäer würden da
im prinzip auch mitmachen verlangen aber
deftige ausgleichszahlungen die sie am
liebsten auch im gipfel papier
festgeschrieben haben möchten
das wiederum ist in westeuropa in zu
konkret und sie wollen eben sich noch
nicht festlegen wie viel geld eigentlich
von west nach ost gezahlt werden soll
und dann gibt es noch diesen zweiten
riss der heute plötzlich auftauchte da
geht es um die atomkraft kann atomkraft
eigentlich als grüne technologie gelten
tschechien ungarn und auch die franzosen
sehen das positiv und schon findet sich
der gipfel mitten drin in einer
diskussion darüber wie man eigentlich
welchen weg man eigentlich richtung
klimaschutz bestreiten will
ob es heute zu einer erklärung kommt
dass die 27 dafür sind die eu bis zum
jahr 2050 klimaneutral zu machen
da stehen die chancen am abend 50 50 an
den vielen dank nach brüssel
in frankreich gehen die proteste gegen
die umstrittene rentenreform von
präsident der manuell makro weiter
gewerkschaften hatten zu aktionen im
ganzen land und zu einer demonstration
in paris aufgerufen der gesamte
zugverkehr war massiv gestört und das
schon den achten tag hintereinander
betroffenen auch wieder die metro in
paris nach angaben der größten
eisenbahngewerkschaft könnten sich die
streiks über die weihnachtstage hinaus
hinziehen
die diplomatische krise um einen
mutmaßlichen auftragsmord in berlin wird
größer nun weist russland zwei deutsche
diplomaten außenminister heiko maas
kritisiert das als völlig
ungerechtfertigt
nach dem mord an einem georgier im
tiergarten hatte die bundesregierung
vergangene woche 2 russen aus gewesen
der grund die bundesanwaltschaft hat
anhaltspunkte für einen tötungsauftrag
russischer stellen der tatverdächtige
ist in haft und schweigt
um die gaspipeline nord stream 2 gibt es
schon länger streit zwischen deutschland
und den usa jetzt hat das
us-repräsentantenhaus sanktionen auf den
weg gebracht nach ansicht washingtons
macht sich deutschland vom russischen
gas abhängig die bundesregierung
verbittet sich jede einmischung durch
die nord stream pipeline soll ab
kommendem jahr gas von russland nach
deutschland geliefert werden nur ein
teilstück vor der insel bornholm fehlt
noch noten eines die arbeiten an
nordstream 2 gehen auch heute weiter
unbeeindruckt von sanktionsdrohungen im
frachthafen sassnitz mukran auf rügen
werden die tonnenschweren pipelinerohre
auf transport schiffe verladen
mehr als 1000 kilometer wegstrecke der
pipeline sind schon fertig und 130
kilometer fehlen noch rund um die
dänische insel bornholm sie noch vor
inkrafttreten der sanktionen
fertigzustellen wird nun zum rennen
gegen die zeit
deutschlands erdgasversorger verfolgen
die entwicklung aufmerksam
es geht um grimmig gitarre die
sanktionen noch wirksam werden können
aber ich denke das projekt insgesamt
kann damit nicht mehr verhindert werden
kohler schätzt dass die pipeline bis
mitte januar fertig gebaut werden kann
jetzt kommt es darauf an wie schnell der
us-senat den sanktionen zustimmt und
präsident trump sie unterschreitet
eine dramatische videobotschaft des us
senators ted cruz warnt nord stream zwei
stühle milliarden in moskaus kassen für
finstere machenschaften
die zeit sei gekommen schnell zu handeln
in berlin ist die empörung groß die
europäische energiepolitik wird in
europa entschieden nicht in den usa
twittert bundesaußenminister maas und
die linke mit ihm bei für uns ist es
eine wirklich beispiellose und
rechtswidrige einmischung der usa in
europäische und auch in deutsche politik
ist ein weiterer tiefpunkt es hat in der
vergangenheit viele gegeben der
transatlantischen beziehungen schon 2020
soll durch die pipeline eigentlich
russisches erdgas nach deutschland
fließen
ob dieser zeitplan eingehalten werden
kann dazu wollte sich die nord dem zwei
ag heute nicht äußern
die pkw maut gilt als wichtigstes
projekt von bundesverkehrsminister
andreas scheuer ein halbes jahr nach
ihrem scheitern hat der
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestages
jetzt seine arbeit aufgenommen
das gremium soll prüfen warum scheuer
verträge mit den netzbetreibern schloss
noch bevor der europäische gerichtshof
ein urteil fällte das gericht stoppte
die maut im juni jetzt drohen
millionenschwere entschädigungen
die opposition wirft scheuer vor
steuergelder verschwendet zu haben und
jetzt interessante zahlen aus der
wirtschaft die uns alle betreffen die
verbraucherpreise steigen weiter nur
langsam die inflationsrate lag im
november bei 1,1 prozent teurer wurden
nahrungsmittel und mieten billiger
dagegen tanken und heizen das ganze jahr
wird mit einer preissteigerung von 1,5
prozent gerechnet bei einem
gleichzeitigen lohnplus von
voraussichtlich 3,1 prozent macht unterm
strich also ein deutliches plus und die
inflation bleibt 2020 ähnlich niedrig
das sagt die neue ezb chefin christine
lagarde
die europäische zentralbank entschied
weiter 20 milliarden euro in die märkte
zu pumpen jeden monat indem sie
staatsanleihen ankauft banken bekommen
weiter kostenlos kredite beide es um die
wirtschaft im euroraum zu beleben
eines will magath aber anders machen sie
will auch mehr darauf gucken welche
negativen folgen dieser absoluten
niedrigzinsen haben mehr von peter
wagner
bestens gelaunt strahlend offen
christine lagarde weiß was viele von der
ersten frau an der spitze der ezb
außer professionalität noch erwarten
ich habe meinen eigenen stil
interpretieren sie nichts in mich hinein
zweifeln sie mich nicht an ihm messen
sie mich nicht an anderen
ich bin ich und deshalb vermutlich
anders als andere
die französin bekennt sich mehrmals klar
zur preisstabilität als einzige mandat
der ezb und kündigt an die
nebenwirkungen der negativzinsen genau
unter die lupe zu nehmen und sie will
binnen jahresfrist eine neue strategie
für die zentralbanker erarbeiten
zusammen mit parlamenten experten und
vertretern der zivilgesellschaft
wir werden auch über den klimawandel
sprechen und prüfen welchen beitrag hier
leisten können
analysten in aller welt haben lagatz
erste pressekonferenz verfolgt jörg
krämer von der commerzbank sieht licht
und schatten das ist ein völlig anderer
stil auch inhaltlich war es anders
gewesen sie erwähnte dass sie sich
kümmern würde auch um klimafragen das
des klimawandels umfragen der
einkommensungleichheit also alles dinge
die normalerweise weit außerhalb dessen
liegen was geldpolitik normalerweise
macht neue ezb-präsident in neue stil
bei der geldpolitik aber bleibt erstmal
alles beim alten auf das pluszeichen vor
dem zins werden wir noch lange warten
müssen
unter wünscht sie happy holidays so
jetzt in eigener sache erstmal der sport
mit guten nachrichten für sie die zdf
zuschauer ja eigentlich für alle
fußballfans die endspiele der champions
league sind von 2022 an bis 2024 live im
zdf zu sehen
außerdem laufen noch gespräche über
zusammenfassungen der spiele am
mittwochabend hier im free tv
die zdf sportredaktion hatte bereits von
2012 an sechs jahre lang live von der
königsklasse berichtet auch den
finalsieg der bayern gegen dortmund im
wembley 2013
und im laufenden wettbewerb ist bayer
leverkusen raus 0 2 gegen juventus turin
nun geht es in der europa league weiter
somit stehen drei deutsche vereine im
achtelfinale nach leipzig und dem bvb
auch bayern münchen nach einer
rekordserie von sechs siegen in der
gruppenphase und einer schrecksekunde
nur kapselanriss und stauchung im knie
ein bisschen glück im unglück für
kingsley kommen die schlimmen
befürchtungen eines kreuzbandrisses
bestätigten sich nicht
der franzose hatte bayern in führung
geschossen leichtes spiel gegen oft
harmlose londoner die allerdings nach 20
minuten ausglichen
senioren nach einem patzer in bayerns
innenverteidigung tottenhams trainer
mourinho ohne kane & co bei das
weiterkommen schon feststand der für
koman eingewechselte müller zum 2 1
danach das tor des tages durch den
zuletzt kritisierten brasilianer
coutinho
sechs spiele sechs siege ob es im
achtelfinale mit trainer flick
weitergeht wollen die bayern vor
weihnachten entscheiden
überraschung bei den deutschen
volleyballerinnen die titelverteidigerin
aus schwerin sind im halbfinale des
pokals gegen die meisterinnen aus
stuttgart ausgeschieden
zweimal kam schwerin in gelb einen
satzrückstand ausgleichen dann sehen die
2000 zuschauer ihr stuttgarter heimteam
im tie-break im vorteil
angreiferin triste rivers nimmt mehrere
anläufe beim umkämpften matchball im
fünften satz und vollendet schließlich
zum sieg
[Applaus]
die deutschen meisterinnen aus stuttgart
gewinnen das pokal halbfinale mit 3 2
sätzen und stehen im endspiel mitte
februar in mannheim gegen den dresdner
sc 16 februar jetzt christin vielen dank
jede menge rosarote papageien hat man
schon in der sendung jetzt großes glück
in einem der kleinsten tierparks in
deutschland im zoo am meer in
bremerhaven sind eisbär zwillinge zur
welt gekommen
sehr selten so was weltweit gibt es nur
wenige junge eisbären in zoos noch
kuscheln sich die beiden eng an als bei
mama valeska in der sogenannten
wurfhöhle bis zum frühjahr bleiben sie
da und danach können besucher die tiere
in der außenanlage an der wesermündung
bestaunen wo sie dann frische seeluft
schnuppern können heute nacht gibt es
winterliche straßenverhältnisse also
vorsicht bitte wie viel es schneit und
wie lange der schnee liegen bleibt
gleich katja oliver 21 uhr 45 freut sich
marietta slomka auf sie weil berichte
aus großbritannien den ganzen abend über
im zdf programm auf heute de und in der
heute app danke für heute gerne bis
morgen in allen ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren vom
besten wird's gefährlich da kommt
nämlich nicht nur regen sondern vor
allen dingen auch schnee bei
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt wird es
also glatt auf den straßen
das geht schon in der ersten nachthälfte
los im saarland und in rheinland-pfalz
und bis zum frühen morgen erreichen die
schneefälle hessen das südliche
nordrhein westfalen bayern und baden
württemberg
morgen früh geht der schnee hier im
äußersten westen bei 3 bis 7 grad schon
wieder in regen über und am vormittag
ziehen die schneefälle weiter nach osten
erreichen auch den thüringer wald auch
den oberpfälzer und bayerischen wald und
den alpen hat dazu nimmt der wind durch
zu es gibt also schneeverwehungen
besonders auf der schwäbischen alb und
im schwarzwald
im laufe des nachmittags verlassen uns
die schneefälle allmählich und die
schneefallgrenze steigt dann schneit es
nur noch in den mittelgebirgen insgesamt
können in den gipfellagen der
mittelgebirge durchaus zehn bis 20
zentimeter neuschnee fallen die
temperaturen morgen abend liegen so bei
null bis sechs grad
am samstag bleibt es sehr stürmisch bei
uns ist häufig trübes fällt regen in den
mittelgebirgen auch schnee und auch am
dritten advent bleibt es noch sehr
windig und wird mit bis zu 14 grad